are there any brands out there that you  look at and say ah that is an iconic  brand that means that has meant so much  in history but today means nothing I'd  love to get my hands on it  Nintendo why because they're [ __ ] up  like there's no 15 year old like the  fact that Nintendo was not winning  in-app gaming is ludicrous they have the  IP the fact that Kardashian apps and  like and like and minecraft and other  things are winning while while there  isn't a 15 year old that gives a crap  anymore about Mario or Zelda or things  of that nature  that was a huge miss and they got  romantic that it was all about the  council where they made their money  right and they were romantic and they  didn't deploy against the next attention  police and they loud that romance to  kill them